have you had any any um of your Idols or
any of the people that you studied like
reach out to you or yes Kim um cardi
they're all they're both so supportive
and so so kind and sweet to me like and
their fans are kind of together yes I've
realized that cuz I said something
before about little Kim that uh people
didn't like I didn't even say anything
too crazy but nonetheless I got the
brunt of the fans that were like they
were like queen bees is that what they
call them the be and then the cardi B
fans are and then I'm cool with like
offset and cardi so like then like 6
months later I was like I said something
about the song jealousy like I don't
know six months before I came out cuz I
heard it and then all those same people
who were like threatening to murder me
were like bootle K says there's a new
cardian on off I was like good Lord yo
do you have a name for your fans yes
maians is the mafia o the D you know
what I'm saying the Mafia the Mafia the
mob you know are they toxic I don't
think so I I like to tell my fans like
be kind exactly be respectful not even
be kind cuz you don't got to be kind to
people people don't [__] with me all
right that's cool but you be respectful
we here for me we don't pay attention to
anybody else you know what I'm saying
like support who support me support
everybody until they not supportive and
then it's [__] some of toxic fans I
just wonder like who are these people in
real life does that does that make sense
what I'm saying I'm not talking about
your fans cuz you'll see some of these
fans whether it's like the little Kim
fans or the barbs or just some of these
human beings they say things on the
internet that are so crazy I just want
to know what they do from like 8:00 p.m.
to 4:00 p.m. on a Monday right like what
do y'all do in real life nothing nothing
it's just crazy like toxic did you see
that show swarm on Amazon I did see it I
did that's show is crazy crazy ass show
what do you watch on TV what are your
go-tos I like like murder mystery of
course you do is it sexist to say that
like why is that a woman thing like
every woman loves that kind of [__] it
might be like sexist it's a little
sexist but it's also men are [__]
that's why there it is but isn't that
not true look my wife all her friends
everybody I know they all my my mom oh
my god when my mom and my wife get
together they're just [__] binge
watching
serial killer [__] yes it shitty
reenactments with shitty actors oh wow
they're interviewing the the detectives
the fan it's just yeah I like stuff like
that or I like um I like this show
called suits right now I don't suits
that's got the girl who the the the uh
what's Mega marles in it right yeah yes
she's phenomenal in cuz that's like an
older show that kind of just repoed
right on like it stopped in like 2017 I
want to say good though yeah I really
like show like like that mhm
I like I like stuff like that suits gr's
Anatomy um what's the other one um where
Matthew gay
gobler that I can't think of [__]
sick name right
there I can't think of the show name but
people going did you watch Scandal I
like so like Scandal Scandal is fire
yeah shout out to her she's she's lovely
for sure man what was her name on the
show Olivia Olivia Pope yes the fixer
yeah I you know I don't ever want to be
like successful enough to where I would
need to hire someone like
her that's real as [__] cuz Olivia Pope
was just getting her hands dirty bro
like I'm like I don't want to be that
important to ever have to call like
Olivia you know what I'm saying like
real [__] that's some were yeah that's
just another level of uh yeah yeah shout
out to Olivia popo well is is it about
being successful is it because you
[__] up I don't know doing dumb [__]
I don't know bro that's why you call
Olivia because you doing stupid [__]
that is true and then she was
I kind of had like I was like she's into
white guys you know as somebody who's a
Caucasian who's into melanated women I
was
like I was like hell yeah hey the
president's taking that [__] down bro
let's go oh my God is that is that is
that like is that like a niche thing is
that like no I mean I just I so I'm
married to a Mexican woman and my kids
are half Mexican I just don't I'm not
into any I'm not into white women at all
they're kind of like I just don't they
just remind me of like my family you
know like I don't want to [__] somebody
who looks like my cousin you know like
right right so I understand so also like
white women are like it's like when you
go to the candy aisle and like there's
all the packs of M&M's right he's about
to say some real crazy misogynistic sex
sh no no no no no so like a white woman
is like you get the brown bag of M&M's
and like nobody wants the brown bag of
M&M's you want the yellow bag when they
got the peanut butter ones you want like
no one's doing plain M&M's unless it's
all they got you know what I'm saying
like so I kind of damn and I'm I'm just
damn he just white woman on like a
t-shirt but hey but listen I'm also a
plain
Eminem yeah I'm a white man so I also
I'm in I'm I'm like an Eminem mini in
the little tube you
know I just I prefer mine you know I
like I like some peanuts in MY M&M's you
know or some yeah little flavor what
just a little flavor just a little
little flavor and like white women can't
cook like my mom can't cook you know
like she could cook enough like so what
does that look like when growing up with
like a mom that can't cook what do you
well listen listen I my mom can cook
enough but she's listen Thanksgiving at
my house versus Thanksgiving at my
wife's family's house there's just a lot
more seasoning
obviously yeah shout out to my mom and
my aunt and my sister they can't cook
for [__] damn I mean they could cook
like they're here's food you know but
it's like is it like great like right
like my dad can cook better than my mom
my dad Cooks way better than my mom is
your dad white yeah oh but he's like
hillbilly white so I feel like it's a
little different they got a little more
like I don't know like he'll he'll put
like he'll like uh make everything in
bacon grease yeah or he'll have a roast
and he like marinates the roast in
Coca-Cola for like 12 hours and that
[__] is gas [__] that it's also it's
it's fire hell no it's really good I
don't want nothing marinated in no
Coca-Cola you don't drink soda I don't
drink Coca-Cola what do you
drink if you had to drink a soda I like
back the Peppa yo Coke is the wave hell
no if you're going to pick a
soda I like salsa you like a Seltzer
like a white claw or like a more like
regular like just like seltzer water
yeah oh yeah that's gross what a black
cherry salsa fire I'm good I like it cuz
I'm sometimes you just need the bubbles
just a little bubble yeah it's like a
fake soda exactly so you'll do like a
what's the thing called lro lroy I'll do
a lacroy yeah that's fine I mean it's
much healthier than like the high
fructose cord syrup that's in all the
Coca-Cola that I drink Mex Mexican
Coke's the wave in the bottle right
straight cane sugar it's real
[__] it is I don't know